اكد مسؤول بالبتانون للجزيره ان ناقله نفط
تعرضت لهجوم بخليج عدم وقال ان سفينه
لتحالف حارس الازدهار في طريقها لتقديم
العوم واكد المسؤول بالبنتاجون للجزيره
تعرض ناقله النفط لاضرار جراء اصابتها
بصاروخ بالستي مضاد للسفن اطلقه الحوثيون
باليمن واضاف المسؤول بالبنتاجون ان ناقله
النفط لم تبلغ عن وقوع اصابات بين طاقمها
جراء اصابتها
صاروخ هذا وقالت شركه ترافيجورا ان
النيران اشتعلت في الناقله مارلين لواندا
التي تعمل لحسابها بعد استهدافها قرب
سواحل اليمن واكدت الشركه اصابه ناقله
بصاروخ خلال عبورها البحر الاحمر ما تسبب
في اندلاع حريق في صهريج شحن على
متنها
معنا من البنتاغون مراسل الجزيره فادي
منصور فادي ماجديد فيما يتعلق بمصير
هذه الناقله ناقله النفط البريطانيه وما
حدث
معها نعم وفق مسؤول امريكي اكد ان وفق
التقارير الوارده وهي حين تحدثنا اليه لم
تكن بعد تقارير عمليات اي تقارير عسكريه
وارده من المنطقه وفق هذا المسؤول اشار
الى ان حريق كان نشب على متن السفينه اي
وهي ناقله نفط مارلين لواندا جراء اصابتها
بصاروخ بالستي مضاد للسفن اطلقه انصار
الله الحوثيون من الاراضي التي يسيطرون
عليها في اليمن واشار هذا المتحدث بعد ان
كنا نقلنا عن مسؤول في البنتاغون بان
سفينه حربيه تابعه لتحالف حارس الازدهار
في طريقها لاغاثه السفينه جراء نشوم
الحريق قال ان في الواقع هذه السفينه هي
مدمره امريكيه طبعا هذا الحديث كان ق قبل
اكثر من ساعه ولم تكن قد وصلت المدمره
الامريكيه ليس لدينا تحديث فعلي في الوقت
الراهن حول الوضع فيما يتعلق بالسفينه
ناقله النفط وما اذا حصلت عمليه الاغاثه
لها خصوصا بسبب نشوب النيران على متنها
لكن المعلومات التي كنا اشرنا اليها نقلا
عن مسؤول في البنتاغون ان السفير رغم
اعلانها وابلاغها انها تعرضت لاضرار الا
انها لم تبلغ عن وقوع اصابات بين افراد
طاقمها وهذه هي الحادثه الثانيه التي وقعت
يوم الجمعه بتوقيت واشنطن سبق لذلك ان
اعلنت القياده الوسطى ان انصار الله
الحوثيون اطلقوا صاروخا باتجاه المدمره
كارني وان المدمره تعاملت مع هذا الصاروخ
واعترضت و ودمرته في كل الاحوال ضرب ناقله
نفط ونشوب النيران فيها يعتبر من وجهه
النظر
الامريكيه حاله تصعيديه ورغم عدم قول
القياده الوسطى صراحه ان الصاروخ الذي
اسقطته المدمره كارني كان هجوما عليها لكن
ايضا هذه خطوه تصعيديه خصوصا بعد قيام
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا للمره الثانيه
بشكل مشترك مطلع الاسبوع الحالي بضرب
اهداف متعدده داخل اليمن اهداف عسكريه
تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين في ثمانيه
مواقع وتاكيد المتحدثين باسم البنتاغون ان
هذه الضربات لها تاثير فعلي على القدرات
العسكريه لانصار الله وتقود هذه القدرات
الان استمرار هذه الهجمات وهذا التطور
النوعي اليوم بضرب ناقله نفط بريطانيه
يشير الى ان المساله غير منتهيه وان
المواجهه ما بين الولايات المتحده وانصار
الله الحوثيين في خليج عدن وباب المندب
والبحر الاحمر مستمر وبان انصار الله لا
يزالون يمتلكون قدرات كبيره ليس فقط على
الرصد ولكن ايضا على
الاستهداف شكرا لك من البنتاجون مراسل
الجزيره فادي
منصور معنا من الحديده مراسل الجزيره سمير
النمري سمير اذا ماذا عن المتابعات فيما
يتعلق باستهداف الناقله البريطانيه وتاكيد
الناطق باسم الحوثيين بانه جرى استهدافها
واصابتها بان النيران تشتعل في هذه
الناقله نعم عبد القادر بحسب مصدر قيادي
في انصار الله فقد تم استهداف
السفينه البريطانيه وهي سفينه نفط
بريطانيه تحمل على متنها نحو
11000 طن من المواد النفطيه الخام في
صاروخ في مؤخره السفينه بحسب مصدر عسكري
في جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين وقال هذا
المصدر ان هذا الاستهداف تم في تلك
المنطقه من السفينه حفاظا على م قال ارواح
طاقم السفينه الناطق العسكري باسم انصار
الله قال ان السفينه استهدفت بعدد من
الصواريخ
البالستيه البحريه وهذه الصواريخ استهدفت
السفينه في خليج عدن بعد تمكنها من خروج
من باب المندب بحسب متابعاتنا لمواقع
الرادار فان السفينه قد اخفت بياناتها او
تعريفها منذ نحو اربعه ايام بعد تجاوزها
قناه السويس باتجاه البحر الاحمر واستهدفت
عصر اليوم تقول المصادر ان النيران ما
تزال تشتعل فيها منذ عصر اليوم وحتى هذه
الل وحتى هذه اللحظه هذه العمليه عبد
القادر تاتي بعد ساعات فقط من اعلان
الولايات المتحده عن تصدي مدمرات يو اس اس
كارني في البحر الاحمر لصاروخ بالستي
اطلقته جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين تجاه
السفينه واسقطت هذا الصاروخ كما انها تاتي
بعد يوم واحد فقط من اعنان الناطق العسكري
عن اشتباك حدث بينهم وبين قواته وبين
القوات الامريكيه في عدد من المدمرات
والسفن البحريه الموجوده في البحر الاحمر
وخليج عدن وهذا الاشتباك قال ناطق انصار
الله بانه استهدف او تمكنت قواته من
استهداف سفينه حربيه امريكيه واجبر
سفينتين امريكيتين اخريتين من العبور من
باب المندب والتوجه الى مسار اخر هذه
التطورات عبد القادر تاخذ منحا تصعيدي
خطيرا في هذه في هذه الفتره الاخيره خاصه
مع استهداف تقوم به انصار الله للسفن
الامريكيه والبريطانيه في عمق خليج عدن
وهي مناطق تبدو بعيده نسبيا عن مناطق
سيطره انصار الله وهي تبعد نحو 400 كم
السفينه التي تم استهدافها عصر هذا اليوم
من الحديده مراسل الجزيره سميره النمري
شكرا جزيلا
لك